місце де десятиліттями народжувалося
життя і де його ледь не обірвала
російська ракета Такий вигляд тепер має
пологове відділення однієї з лікарень
Дніпра Ну он був приліт якраз під
фундамент там підвал фактично цього
пологового відділення куди прийшовся
удар і в результаті тут пожар був Воно
видно цей пожар тут
перекриття рухнули
вниз ще на першому поверсі в якій
влетіла ракета вигоріли вщент удар був
такої сили що кількатонні плити з бетону
просто повивертало в різні боки ще 27
грудня у цих стінах Ольга огійченко
приймала пологи за два дні після цього
відділення палало просто на її очах я
встала з
автівки відкрила задню дверцю щоб взяти
свої речі був приліт і ми з моєю колегою
якою я Яка теж їхала зі мною на роботу
встигли сісти назад вагітна жінка яка
була госпіталізована і прийшла зранку на
здачу аналізів
ее Ми теж її врятували
ее Вона тільки заходила на приємне
відділення як був прильот е жінка
розтерялася бігала по вулиці Ми її взяли
до себе в машину Таким чином уламки які
летіли не пошкодили
нікого у момент влучання в пологовому
крім медпрацівників перебували 19
пацієнток стаціонару а також четверо
новонароджених Усі вони вціліли лише
завдяки тому що вчасно спустилися в
укриття розповідають
лікарі в пологах нікого не було в
операційній нікого не парували у нас в
всі жінки під час повітряної тривоги
спускалися в укриття Таким чином саме 29
грудня були врятовані життя участково
зруйнований пологовий медпрацівники
приходять ніби в гості до колишнього
життя хтось шукає свої особисті речі а
когось як Катерину сюди привела
ностальгія за улюбленою роботою після
другого курсу в мене тут просто
працювала одногрупниця санітаркою вона
каже Хочеш кажу Конечно хочу і я пішла
да Спочатку санітаркою я працювала
більше року а потім вже Як
закінчила третій курс змогла працювати
медсестрою потім
акушеркою і потім стала вже ось в цьому
році в минулому вже Я закінчила
університет і поступила на інтернатуру і
стала тут лікарем інтерном свої робочі
ранки Катерина починала з обходу
пацієнтів за білими дверима зазвичай
чекали породілля та немовлята а тепер
каже в палати навіть моторошно зазирати
це троянди олічки вони 25 грудня стали
батьками вдруге в нашому полого будинку
Я її навіть зранку зустрічала Ми
готувалися до пологів і це троянди
подарував їй чоловік за народження
донечки другої і оце вони тут так і
залишилися бо тоді ж по тривозі як 29
грудня це все сталося по тривозі вони
були спущені в укриття і тут все таки і
залишилося деякі речі потім забрала
троянди так і стоять ця частина будівлі
вціліла найбільше чимало медичного
обладнання і побутових речей звідси
вдалося винести майже не ушкодженими тут
був пост акушерки пологової
зали тут оце двері ви бачите відчинені
Це була ординаторська де сиділи наші
лікарі чергували
24х7 А оце все по цю сторону це пологові
зали зараз в нас тут тепер так як тут
найвціліліше приміщення ми знесли сюди
деякі меблі деяку техніку в цій частині
будівлі напередодні трагедії завершили
ремонт ми тільки нещодавно поставили ці
двері гарні і тепер тут немає скла Тут
також було все вибиті всі вікна все було
звалено зараз тут конечно вже пусто того
що ми все винесли звідси майже тиждень
після трагедії медпрацівники разом із
рідними та друзями розчищали завали і
виносили сміття також на допомогу
прийшли десятки містян ось це до речі
стоїть бак ще хлопці не винесли тут скло
яке ми збирали операційній тут де
операційна медсестра знаходилася збирали
різали пальці собі на руках на ногах
того що як замітаєш воно все
піднімається і маленькі оці осколочки
вони залітають в чоботи було порізано
все за словами керівництва медзаклад уже
не вперше потерпає від російської
агресії ну було 170 вибито восстановили
все зробили працювали ну зараз близько
900 розміри Битків ще не підраховували
але вони масштабні- каже директор
лікарні нам допоможуть вікна допомагають
благодійники допомагають різні
організації надіємося Ну а по
відновленню полового відділення це
велике питання ми також проводимо роботу
з різними
організаціями також проводимо роботу з
нашим
міністерством Ну як Якось получиться
сумно Ну ми
намагаємося і в соціальних мережах
виставляти ролики для того щоб небайдужі
люди нам допомагали у нас відкритий
рахунок він прозорий видно скільки
поступають коштів туда на цей рахунок чи
вдасться повністю відновити будівлю
наразі невідомо тим часом найбільша мрія
працівників якнайшвидше відбудувати
відділення аби у цих стінах знову
народжувалися діти
Ой
це просто удар по
серцю дуже хотілося щоб відновили наш
пологовий будинок Я як можна швидше тому
що саме в пологовому тут народжується
життя